I'm not gonna fill me this guy lesson
learn ready for some action
cuz I'm worth it thumbs up thumbs up
Neena proof I'm not gonna be skeptical
I'm going to be a believer
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
good morning Nina
how you feeling it's a day at sea today
we're gonna go get some breakfast it is
like 10:30 something up a step
last night I went to bed around 1:00
woke up around 10:00
so like me in that pass Senate then had
to wake up at 3 to press your teeth and
then stayed after office you couldn't
sleep anymore
so good though it's a date see so no
major planes gonna do some book work I'm
gonna do some YouTube video work do this
some more pet it is relaxing gonna do
some drinking we're gonna do some food
eating we have a special restaurant
booked tonight and let's start the day
get some food
[Music]
all right lesson learned
found the sink use that the clean-out
pants now I'm gonna get food again and
I'm not gonna film it this time lesson
learned
[Music]
all right this is round one for me a
nice healthy breakfast is over here
happy breakfast thank you with a copy
Nina round two fruits and yogurt where
you going
Mina's looking for round two
[Music]
is that worth it so I'm filming a video
for the channel this is my setup it's a
chair against the beautiful waves of the
backdrop and to make that happen I have
a table and a barstool and a garbage can
and a book but the final product will be
amazing
hey what's up at seven I am coming to
you from the North Sea somewhere between
Denmark and Germany right now
alright filming is done took me about 20
25 minutes hopefully this sound came out
okay cuz I got the waves crash behind me
I'm gonna go check in see what Nina's
doing we're gonna get to you with a name
alright playing we're gonna go upstairs
we're gonna get some coffee I'm gonna
work on the book whoa good you guys
gonna do some Sudoku and ready Nia
ready for some action ready for some
action before getting to work we're
gonna get some coffee
Nina's getting now what are you getting
yeah I'm getting a cappuccino
you see outcomes all right we found our
spot
got our drinks looking out over the
balcony and the unpack the computer it's
a work here we go it's right in time all
right so this is gonna take way longer
than I anticipated we sat there how long
we were there for we're there for a
while and I've only done three people
out of the 50 just for viewing what
they're saying
formatting spelling structure all that
stuff takes a long time no it's gonna
take me a long time to finish but the
goal is to get it all done by the time I
get back to Toronto so we've done three
out of 50 and I got a lot of my work to
do right now hustle hashtag hustle what
are we doing now Lina's hungry you want
to go for lunch
no sex we're gonna get needed some
snacks and then continue the hustle
[Music]
that's a lot of snack that's a snack
they have strawberry rhubarb crumble oh
my god I'm gonna have
I'm not really hungry I got my
cappuccino still I'm going to finish
that off and then maybe get some food
[Music]
and it's back to work for me round two
of the snack is soup what kind of soup
is it good it's round two of a snack
kind of feels like a lunch still a snack
that whole thing that's just a snack
though I mean that's starting to feel
nauseous up here in the 12th deck so
we're gonna head back to the room let
our light down [ __ ]
[Music]
all right so I have reviewed one page
131 out of 428 and is eighty-nine
thousand words to go through and it took
a long time but I'm making some good
progress it was 25% of the way so Nina
and I both got a little bit seasick and
relax and watch the movie romantic
comedy mean I enjoy it a lot she was
having a lot of fun she was laughing a
lot still feeling a little bit headache
how you feeling how to shower I'll just
crash into the wall there we have dinner
reservations at and I can eat your
zillion Steakhouse so good thing we
didn't eat too much how hungry are you
I'm not you're not that hungry either
but maybe we'll get hungry as the food
comes out so we're gonna go find our
restaurant and enjoy our evening
[Music]
so we dine at our own pace there's a
market also turned upside down we have a
salad bar and then we get the pic it's a
a steady flow as much as we want of all
of this stuff should be exciting
[Music]
all right appetizer round one
it's mine Nina's guy so bill to sell it
to brown feels a little bit lighter for
me just a little bit of shrimp pasta the
mozzarella di bufala awesome shape
cheese and then we have to flip our
cards over to green when we start
getting meat
[Music]
how you feeling Nina we turned our cards
over to stop the inflow of food still
catching up we're super full but we
wanted more pineapple cinnamon pineapple
thumbs up thumbs up you know proof all
right we are done we are full yeah real
full how you doing Nina Paul it's
filling and the boats really moving a
lot so we're on the top deck of the boat
so you feel it a lot more as we get back
to the cabin relax us off a little bit
Nina I brought your wine with her and
then after maybe an hour so once we've
worn this off come back to deck 12 and
get some strawberry rhubarb dessert with
ice cream for Nina I'll find something
you know some water nice healthy salad
and yeah what do you think I'll head
back out in an hour I'll get my dessert
and you know probably another drink
maybe another night yeah
all right got the page 169 starting to
crash out from the wave so Nina and I
gonna head up to the deck and try to get
some food and that'll help so it's nine
nineteen at night got another cabin
gonna go get some food
check it out one of the cabin stewards
came by Nina told him good morning
that's how I stoned out were feeling
across I'm gonna check out that little
patch I don't if we can buy it now helps
with seasickness oh you're on go they
want to go there first
we were their first fight close but we
have one more date see so it helped for
that
[Music]
all right they don't have what I'm
looking for but they have something else
what did you find Nina I'm very
skeptical at sixteen US dollars but
we'll give it a shot
I'm willing to be proved wrong over some
giant bottles $330 great goosed bottle
huge check Nina's gonna put it on you I
need to sit down for this
no stand up okay just you're a lot
shorter than I am I'm gonna reach okay
one drop behind that's it
really the whole points this is huh
is this passivity two times oh I feel so
much better now good good but that it's
also alleviate I'm not gonna be
skeptical I'm going to be a believer
this is gonna oh my god see working okay
believe believe in that was this called
promotion is top top motion is topical
oil I believe in you let's make it
happen a chair more let's go get some
strawberry rhubarb with ice cream laughs
Nina the rhubarb is gone
there was a lunch time only thing it's
very sad I don't know I don't know it's
very sad it's a sad day let's go look
together you can hold my hand make me
feel better very sad
[Music]
all right so I got some cheeseburger
pizza some pasta it's an apple strudel
that I'm gonna add some ice cream and
caramel sauce sometimes there is final
product get some butterscotch sauce you
know got red wine okay back to the room
let's go
Nina's motion sickness gun that oil
worked all right I want to get to a
lower deck so it's not shaky as much
here we go all right I got the page 216
of 428 which officially puts me at more
than halfway through the book of spell
checking and format in reviewing which
makes me very excited I'm gonna end on
Joe Rogan I'm just about to start going
through jewelry and stuff so it's taking
me way longer than I anticipated to get
this stuff done but it's important that
it's done right you know I want I want
this book to be something that is that
is legendary I want this book to be
something that's legendary that's right
Nina
I like that Nina how you feeling with
the hole so good I feel a little better
no no that I feel good I feel better
maybe I should put it maybe I should do
a real application for bed time maybe
anyway it is almost midnight we are
going to arrive early tomorrow morning
at Hamburg and we need to
[Music]
really okay then we definitely get the
behead go see Hamburg explore the town
and I bet you they want to be in this
video don't film me but but but hear me
hear me in this video you will hear my
voice the voice of Nina and okay Nina
any other final messages that you want
to continue to believe
[Music]
and we'll see you soon bye guys hope you
have a great weekend